[Music]
your life slips away from you you know
changing your phone number in your email
becomes normal
[Music]
taking out a restraining order normal
relocating to another city normal but
you still see your stock or everywhere
rationally I know this is my imagination
but I'm alone in a strange city and I
never feel safe would there's some more
forms you need to fill out it's just
routine I finished my homework so your
Valentini please follow me what okay I
don't have a lot of time I should be
back at work so what am i doing in here
take off your clothes down to your
underwear I'm not sure what's happening
here the door's locked
it would be better for everyone
especially yourself if you just do as I
ask
there's been some kind of mistake by
signing this you've consented to
voluntary commitment I am being held
here against my will do you know how
many calls the cops get like that every
week those are some crazy people
[Music]
he's followed me all the way here from
Boston my stalker is here we did a
thorough background check you should be
protecting me mom no one believes me I'm
getting you out there's nothing we can
do unless you have to prove that a
crimes been committed
I must be insane saying my mom didn't
pick up last night
hello there's been saying what happened
to her dead body was discovered he's
here or maybe it's all in my head
[Music]